Chris Rock didn't pull any punches on
Will Smith in his new Netflix special
and those repeated blows reportedly have
Smith's ears ringing Netflix's first
Live Comedy event was always going to
stir the part selective outrage Chris
Rock's latest special for the streamer
tackled everything from wokeness to the
Ukraine Invasion to Meghan Markle of
course a major hook of the night was
that rock of my address Will Smith's
Infamous Oscar slap though rocks took
his time getting there he eventually
delivered on this expectation after
teasing his thoughts throughout the
program Rock finally Unleashed his true
feelings about the slap the people I
didn't hurt it still hurts
I got summertime ringing in my ears
referencing the title of the special
rocker Q Smith of selective outrage and
ignoring the alleged damage that his
wife Jada Pinkett Smith had inflicted
upon him when she cheated on him because
considering goal of the visceral against
the Smiths and the special fans
naturally began to wonder if either of
the actors had taken a peek at selective
outrage it has now become apparent that
one of them pointedly did not Will Smith
has spent the last year working on his
reputation even using his emancipation
press tour to describe his recent
emotional growth that realization that
uh nobody gets out of bearing their
cross according to sources who spoke
with Entertainment Tonight he
consequently felt that Rock's special
had engaged in excessive criticism
especially considering that Smith had
spent so much time in self-reflection
the source explained will is embarrassed
and hurt by what Chris said about him
and his family in his Netflix special he
didn't watch it but he had people tell
him what Chris said Smith was also
reportedly upset with Netflix for a lot
in rock time to speak about the slap in
the special rock also devoted
significant time to criticizing Jada
Pinkett Smith he spent some time
pointing out the absurdity of 2020 red
table talk episode in which she admitted
to having a past relationship with the
singer August Alsina as rock said in his
special we've all been cheated on none
of us have ever been interviewed by the
person that cheated on us on television
she hurt him way more than he hurt me
okay even outside of his selective
outrage special and his job at Pinkett
Smith at the 2022 Oscars Rock has a
history of poking fun at the Scream 2
actress Jada Pinkett Smith apparently
once told a comedian not to host the
2016 Oscars due to her husband not
getting nominated for the film
concussion well Rock rejected that
suggestion and drawing his opening
monologue hosting the ceremony Rock told
the crowd Jada boycotting the Oscars is
like me boycotting Rihanna's panties I
wasn't invited rock also used his time
on stage at the 2016 Oscars to make some
jokes about Will Smith saying it's not
fair that Will was this good and didn't
get nominated it's also not fair that
Will was paid 20 million dollars for
Wild Wild West
[Music]
according to et's sources Pinker Smith
has already read about some of the
pointed remarks rock made about her in
selective outrage in any case whether or
not she has any ill will towards a
comedian rocks comments about Pinkett
Smith are surely another reason why Will
Smith expressly did not watch Rock's
special meanwhile the audience clearly
loved Chris Rock's like devout rage and
the consensus seems to be Universal
Chris Rock slapped
foreign
[Music]